And one last thought about this, this um,
fiasco yesterday in the Rose Garden, I want
to play again the clip of Nancy Pelosi, just
the very end of her, her speech where she
said she's going to pray for the president
and the United States of America play that
clip.
He just took a pass.
And it just makes me wonder why, why he did
that.
In any event, I pray for the president of
the United States and I prayed for the United
States of America.
So heres the thing, this amounts to me to
being nothing more than when Republicans respond
to gun violence with thoughts and prayers
when they have the capacity to do something
about it.
Right?
Maybe she was just trying to convey, and I
said this earlier, perhaps he was just trying
to convey a seriousness, a somberness, um,
uh, tone of, um, of a tone that is reflective
of how dire the situation is.
But that's just the thing if you're trying
to convey to the American people that this
situation is so bad that it requires a moment
of reflection and uh, a deep, somber moment,
uh, appealing to a divine intervention into
our affairs.
If that's what you truly believe, then you
as speaker of the house need to stop praying
and start impeachment.
Don't pray impeach like why you are literally
the one person in this country who has the
ability to, if not get rid of the president,
put him on notice with the official articles
of impeachment.
Because all you need in the house is a simple
majority.
Draw up the articles and vote and he can see
and the record could reflect that there was
true opposition, not just the Hashtag movements,
not just the actual real movements that are
in the streets, like the movements that are
actually doing things, but using our, our
constitutional institutions.
And, and, uh, and, and regimes and norms to
actually do what the constitution said that
you should do, Nancy Polosi if you feel that
is this dire of a situation.
So I'm sorry, just like we respond to thoughts
and prayers by politicians when some, some,
some kid goes and shoots up another kid at
a school and they respond with thoughts and
prayers.
And we dismissed that because it's useless
as there's nothingness.
They're guy like, you know, as much as I'm
a believer, like my favorite scripture is
faith without works is dead.
So you're sitting there praying and you ain't
doing nothing about it.
God doesn't even recognize that.
Right?
So, I mean, and then forget about divine intervention
when you have the capacity and the tools at
your disposal to actually do something about
it.
But instead you're going to pray for the president.
Don't pay her.
Pray for that man.
You're going to pray for the United States
of America.
Well, thank you.
But you know what?
Don't pray.
Impeach.